[Music]
as soon as you
say retirement it's time to call it
that's it
okay you're getting oh my god
hey mike yeah what you do with
i'm making moves put your hands together
for the rowdy
shroudies
i feel like i could pick up a new game
never played it before
and do really good you know
all right so it's me hello
bro that was insane
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
dude
once upon a time michael shroud gazette
was a crispy
charismatic counter-strike competitor
one of the most
naturally talented nutcases north
america
had ever seen still gets the kill it
almost looked like skadoodle had
actually come out on top there
what a flick coming in trout getting one
of the headshots he's tapping away
shroud
can he do it again he's up to 11 kills
and looking for number 12
are you kidding me shroud four kills
can anyone take this man down but you
already know that
molotov's in set piece out shroud has
let them all pass
one two
[Music]
you also know that after hanging up the
shroud for good midway through 2018
he began to cement himself as the
universally adored variety streamer he
is today
an affable authentic phenom who couldn't
help but become the
jack of jaw-dropping trades aimbot we
know and love
hold on hold on good luck open good luck
all right let's go let's go let's go
let's go to pink patrick
oh my god you watched a shroudy rowdy
went from a fan
favorite to a rock star beheld as mr
cs go clips himself became mr all clips
watched as the king of reddit became the
king of twitch
mixer twitch again and well
pretty much anything involving shooting
dudes in the face
little counter strike action baby the
thing is
since then somehow someway
he's gone from a big deal to a freaking
deity
wait i added it we're fine holy shizen i
don't have time
oh my god i feel bad i just
the streamer who makes even other
streamers into fanboys
the die-hard down-to-earth savant who
sold out without ever actually doing it
the most influential head clicker on the
internet
and godfather of an entire esports genre
the one egamer who all others aspire to
be
[Music]
how well in order to tell that story
we've got to go all the way back to 2018
when battle royales were all the rage
and our boy was still solidifying
himself
as one of the biggest streamers on
twitch and
not unrelatedly the most recognizable
aimer
on the platform
and at the end of the day that's what
set shroud apart
his inhuman ability to pick up a shooter
any shooter
and just be a god at it it didn't matter
if it was
tactical arena oriented or a battle
royale
if it involved placing a crosshair on a
head and clicking
he was certifiably unreal i don't want
negan ready
here we go
mirrors in closet
let's go it wasn't just that shroud
played
pretty much every fps known to man it
was how seamlessly he hopped from one
game engine
to another making pixel perfect peaks at
every turn
shroud played everything and he played
it well
what's more if shroud played it the game
did well
by the end of 2018 shroud had
established himself as pretty much the
most revered fragger on twitch
it didn't matter how old you were what
game you came from
or what you were playing now if you had
a chance to come within a country mile
of shroud
you took it hello hello bulow oh bueller
i don't know yeah that's the one call
you bow yeah
because when all was said and done he
truly was
in a league of his own it wasn't just
about his mechanics
but also his humble salt of the earth
way he slapped people
he was this sweet sincere super chill
specter of death whose beatdowns came to
be regarded as
blessings of a sort both by super fans
okay you're getting oh my god it's
shroud oh
just killed me and other world renowned
streamers
he glitched glide off the rock man
that's okay oh [ __ ] that's okay
what i'll say about mike is that his
like
temperament what's really cool about him
is you feel like
he's pretty much mike across the board
like i don't think
i've seen someone like peer pressure
mike in a sense
out of game and game to do what he
doesn't want to do mike's going to grab
a beer mic will have his one beer you
ask for once a second he'll tell you if
he doesn't want a second beer
if you want like to do a play-in game
he's not comfortable to play he'll
tell you i'm down or i'm not down pretty
straightforward and mike's kind of this
way across the board
when 2019 hit there were two super
streaming horses
on top of twitch the og shroud
and the [ __ ] face of fortnite ninja
with whom shroud had developed a rivalry
of sorts
in a lot of ways shroud was the opposite
of the all
too theatrical face of fortnite and his
reputation
only grew as he continued to bang out
what he wanted
when he wanted how he wanted
no oh i dodged it i dodged it what's up
what's up what's up
oh my god okay
shroud's laid back laissez-faire ownage
had always been his hallmark
but over the course of 2019 it became
his
multi-million dollar meal ticket the
quintessential quirk
of one of the truly successful twitch
persona to whom even the hardiest of
e-gamers flocked
this is crazy oh my gosh dude this is
crazy
oh my god everything's shaking what do
we do
this is insane oh shoot holy [ __ ]
this is insane
what do we do what do we do what do we
do what do we do
come the frame we need this ring it's
very strange because
like i said i'm just myself when i'm
gaming and i i never really
truly realize how much impact i have
um and i get all those people that say
that i'd help them so much just by
watching my stream it's an amazing thing
but yeah
it's weird because you don't expect that
you're just a normal dude just playing
video games and you make people happy
it's
strange and then in august something
insane happened something no one saw
coming
the button steve
[Applause]
ninja's exclusivity deal with mixer was
first reported to be valued at anywhere
from 30
to 50 million dollars and when it first
went public
it looked as if twitch could simply be
shrouds for the taking
how much would they have to pay you to
move i don't know i don't have the
answer to that question
it's not something that's on my mind it
the problem
it's like i am in a
i'm in a position where i don't really
have to go anywhere
you know shroud had always been twitch
royalty
but at this point it was starting to
feel as if he was an
unofficially agreed upon ruler this
actual bonafide celebrity who everyone
in gaming admired for his refusal to be
anything but himself put your hands
together
for the rowdy shroudies
[Applause]
your lineup is the one and only russian
badger macy j
chai saslin and shroud
and then just two months later shroud
made an earth-shattering announcement
of his own hey mike yeah what you do
with i'm making moves because he misses
you
oh hi benji
just as the king of the fortnight
kitties was abdicating his throne and it
was starting to look as if twitch's real
king
might finally take his rightful place at
the top shroudy rowdy
followed suit signing a reportedly
eight-figure exclusivity deal
with microsoft's scrappy new streaming
service mixer
all right so
it's me hello from the outside looking
in
shroud's platform change didn't change
all that much
he was still the same savant everyone
knew and loved
if anything the move increased his
already absurd name recognition
i should have killed a man what did he
do
oh i didn't even see him
why'd you pump me against these people
who asked for this because no matter how
far removed from his professional career
he became
shroud was never not cracked he didn't
get
old or out of practice the man was
simply incapable
of being washed what i think what i'm
most known for
is for aim but i think that's not
actually
true i think what what
my talent is and what i personally think
i should be
most known for is
my ability to adapt to any game
i feel like i could pick up a new game
never played it before and do really
good
you know
what is he doing
okay that said while he was making big
bucks
the mixer move did take its toll on
shroud's viewership
sure he'd earned himself a fat check and
no one denied that it was worth it
but since the platform itself was
failing
he'd also earned his metrics some f's in
the chat
you can't really test streams out
because like
even to this day like people have no
idea
that i'm on mixer you know
there's so many people who just thought
i quit streaming they just don't know
flash forward to april 2020
twitch was thrust into an fps frenzy
as riot games gave streamers the chance
to draw beta keys
in an effort to promote their
counter-strike inspired hero shooter
valorant unfortunately shroud couldn't
participate
given that he wasn't on twitch needless
to say
this wasn't ideal for shroud or for
valorant here you have this former cs go
competitor who
in addition to adoring shooters of all
kinds also loved ability-driven games
it seemed like a match made in heaven
and well
was you really think valerian is really
good it's incredible
like i can't say i can't say anything in
detail but i can tell you is
it's one of the greatest games i've
played in a very very very long time
within no time it became apparent that
shroud had stumbled upon his new
go-to shooter and christ was he cracked
at it
bro that was insane
fans even began to speculate whether
he'd consider taking a crack at
professional play
and sure enough by shroud's own
admission it crossed his mind
honestly i really would i really would
love to go pro in this game i would
i i i would be lying if i said i'd
you know i didn't want to i would love
to but it's just not realistic
and i'm smart enough to know that right
here's the thing though
mixer was actually doing so poorly that
ironically
it ended up working in shroud's favor
why
well between the coven 19 pandemic and
viewership becoming so
lackluster in summer of 2020 microsoft
shocked the streaming world again they
shut down
mixer entirely yesterday mixer announced
that they'll be
ceasing their operations completely
microsoft's answer to twitch
and the organization that signed shroud
and ninja to multi-million dollar
exclusivity deals
is no more now for a lot of honest
hard-working streamers who'd been trying
to make a living on mixer
that was scary but for shroud it was a
payday
so now mixer um
cannot accomplish its deliverable
of having a platform to stream on so
mixer
makes a deal with facebook gaming
to transfer the value
of the contracts to transfer
shroud and ninja over to facebook gaming
shroud was reported to have been fielded
a downright ridiculous offer by facebook
gaming
which he reportedly declined
realistically
there was only one platform whereby the
rowdy one
could make his triumphant return the
place
where it all started
his first day back shroud amassed over
half a million
concurrent viewers this wasn't just a
return
stream it was a coronation the one true
king of twitch
was back dude i can't even read i can't
read anything there's literally i can't
read
a single thing in this chat room nothing
absolutely nothing look at all of these
twitch primes
damn it feels good to say that again
twitch
pride needless to say shroud's return to
twitch has also done wonders for
valorant
as an esport both because he's well
absolutely
nasty at it
ten seconds left
and because of the bridge he's creating
between the casual
and competitive fan bases oh
my five players coming up oh my god oh
my god
oh he's gotta catch some flack and he
gets to the end
one for free make it two oh my
in many ways shroud has quite literally
become
the voice of valor and esports his watch
parties have started to decimate the
official streams in terms of viewership
and he's all but cemented himself as the
face
figurehead and authority figure of
riot's
still burgeoning shooter this map is by
far
the most entertaining map to watch you
know even flanking
fields it doesn't feel like a [ __ ] show
i would describe it
and yet in the months since his
record-breaking comeback
things have pretty much gone right back
to normal shroud is still dishing out
filthy unthinkable frags
i have yeah bullets his legion of fans
still hound him
for his take on absolutely everything
what's up when you eat a taco do you
till your head or the taco
[ __ ] i should have been looking at you
oh [ __ ] oh god i was
i was thinking how do i eat and he still
has
well uh you know pubic hair style penis
size
wait
what hold on
perfect perfect we're looking damn good
he continues to play whatever whenever
no matter the expectation
[Music]
and remains entirely unafraid to say and
do
whatever the [ __ ] he wants among us what
did you choose
no i don't play among us i only play
real games
anyway what did you do
hold on
[Music]
shroud isn't just a streamer he's an
authority
an aficionado everyone who's ever
touched a first-person
shooter adores and aspires to be him
and they trust him too i love cs i love
it i'd love to play it
i can't accept the fact that i know i'm
gonna jump in and just get cheated
every single time use face it that's my
point the fact that you have to use
third party
what makes this game better than valrant
in this currency or better than cs in
this current state
is that you jump in you press play
you're good that's it that's all you do
in cs if you're a newcomer how are you
supposed to know about faces
esea any of those things and even if you
do know
about them how are you supposed to trust
them the only people you trust are the
people behind the game
so you want to jump into their service
and press play and you're good to go
you can't do that in cs because it's
garbage
the thing that makes shroud such a
unicorn is that he became
big not by following trends but by
bucking them
he's this nonchalant maestro who somehow
managed to become
massively mainstream without ever losing
his street cred just got out of walmart
and i bought like 12 cans of madrinas
even though i get that [ __ ] for free
just won't let you guys know flex
maddie
[Music]
because at the end of the day the
singularity of shroud
lies in his ubiquity the fact that he's
the one streamer who
everyone from 8th graders to 30 year old
accountants
thinks he's a badass it's safe to say
that shroudy rowdy is
the closest thing twitch has to a great
equalizer
it's also safe to say that he always
will be
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this
hit the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite size
videos you won't find
anywhere else hit up our instagram
twitter and facebook pages